amy coney barrett's nomination cruises
ahead as democrats struggle for a
response
president trump tests negative for
coveted while the media frets
selectively about masking
and portland rioters knock over statues
of abraham lincoln and teddy roosevelt
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protection or online privacy
today at expressvpn.com all right we
have a lot to get to today we'll get to
everything involved in the amy coney
barrett hearings will also get to joe
biden who continues to stumble over
himself but
it turns out that that doesn't matter
because in the end he is making this
thing a referendum on trump we'll get to
all that in just
one second first we are in the final
days leading up to one of the most
contentious
presidential elections in our nation's
history what happens if joe biden wins
what if the outcome is uncertain
what if we only have eight supreme court
justices i mean lots of things can
happen what if the democrats try to
quarterback okay bottom line is that
uncertainty is terrible for markets
at the very least it creates volatility
in the markets and this is why you
should be diversified at least a little
bit
into precious metals so do what i do
diversify into gold with birch gold just
like i've been telling you to do
for years now wouldn't it be nice how
layer of security whichever way the wind
blows
you certainly would have found that
helpful if you had done what i said back
in 2016
2017 text ben 247 4747 one of the nice
people at birch gold will walk you
through your conversion of your eligible
ira or 401k
into a precious metals ira where the
physical metal not etfs will be stored
securely birch gold they're people that
i trust i've been working with them for
years they have an a plus rating with
the better business bureau countless
five-star reviews go talk to them right
now
they're extremely knowledgeable ask all
of your questions when you feel
comfortable
invest with the team at birch gold text
ben 247 47
47 buy some gold or open a precious
metals ira today again
text ben to 47 47 47
okay so yesterday launched the amy coney
barrett hearings and it became
quickly obvious that the democrats have
no line of attack against amy coney
barrett now the truth was they had no
line of attack against brett kavanaugh
either he was a very well qualified
jurist
and not only was he well-qualified but
he had not
really ruled on anything particularly
controversial coney barrett has not
controversial
she's made some statements in her law
review articles about how originalism
ought to be interpreted
and those statements are well in line
with traditional originalist philosophy
so democrats really don't have a great
line of attack and therefore they've
come up with two lines of attack
on amy coney bear one is that she's
something out of the handmaid's tale
michael moore yesterday
tweeted out a a miscolorized photo
of amy coney bear she was wearing what
looked like a purple
slash pink outfit yesterday and he
re-touched it up so that she was wearing
red
and then he tweeted out that she was a
member of the handmaid's tale because as
it turns out every woman who has ever
worn red
is a member of the sex cult in the
handmaid's tale
right it's great so that means elizabeth
warren elena kagan
sonia sotomayor hillary clinton nancy
pelosi
michelle obama all of whom have worn red
at one point or another the only reason
that a woman would ever wear red
is because she's a member of a cult from
the margaret atwood novel
the other possibility of course is that
it has not i mean first of all you have
to miscolorize the photo but second of
all
like it turns out this is just stupid so
one attack on coney barrett is that
she's religious
and all religious people are bigots and
all bigots ought to be kept off the
court
and that line of attack is very
dangerous for democrats they've been
shying away from that one a little bit
the other one
is that it is just illegitimate for
republicans to fill the seat republicans
should never under any circumstances
fill the seat because republicans did
not fill
the merrick garland seat they didn't
vote on merrick garland
well the reason they didn't vote on
merrick garland is because merrick
garland didn't have the votes
it turns out that they didn't have 51
votes for merrick garland they do have
51 votes as it turns out
for amy tony baird so they were left
with pretty much nothing except
screaming and muelling and whining and
yelling at the moon
now one of the questions here is how
this is going to affect the presidential
race
a lot of people including me speculated
that if democrats went overboard here it
would hurt joe biden
in the same way that going overboard
against brett kavanaugh and calling him
a gang rapist
hurt democrats for a brief moment in
time before trump redirected the
nation's attention toward the caravan
the the illegal immigrant caravan moving
up through central
america central and latin america now
the democrats have been careful not to
do that they've been careful to avoid
that particular issue also it turns out
i don't think the amy coney barrett
hearings are going to have much to do
with the election
on a presidential level on a senate
level they could have something to do
with it and i know everybody in the
world i've been saying this for now
a week i know everybody in the world
wants to focus in on the presidential
race here are the facts about the
presidential race right now
it is not a close race that is the
simple fact of the matter right now
by polling data it is not a particularly
close raise joe biden
has been up consistently in double
digits for at least three weeks
joe biden in every single swing state is
at least
running dead even or ahead that is
according to the polls
now could it be that donald trump is
going to pull out a
from behind victory at the last minute
absolutely there's still time it is also
possible that the polls are off although
they would have to be off by
probably an order of magnitude in order
for them to be wrong nationally and for
trump to somehow win the popular
national vote but he's within spitting
distance in florida he's been spitting
distance in ohio
these are all very close states he's not
really within spinning distance right
now in pennsylvania wisconsin or
michigan according to the latest polling
data he's going to have to draw closer
there
but recognize that if you're a
conservative he's not the only person on
the ballot
it turns out that your senate candidates
are on the ballot as well
and joe biden as president with a
democratic senate is significantly more
dangerous to the future of the republic
than joe biden as president with the
republican senate
especially given the fact that there
tends to be an off-year election
blowback against the party in power in
the executive branch which means that if
republicans were to hold the senate this
time around
then you would imagine they would pick
up some seats there's a bad map for them
you'd imagine they would pick up some
seats
next time around and strengthen that
senate majority
and so you have a number of close senate
races the acb hearings
actually benefit republicans in this way
because democrats
acting like idiots particularly from
purple states that does not cut in favor
of those senate candidates
and right now we are starting to see
some evidence that there will be some
ticket splitting
that that wouldn't be a huge surprise
there was some of this in 2018
there were races that republicans were
supposed to lose and they ended up
winning the most obvious one is ron
desantis in florida he was running
against andrew gillum the media
basically suggested that gillum was a
foregone conclusion and then andrew
gillum not only lost but ended up
in a uh in a hotel room with a gay
hooker and some meth so it turns out
good decision floridians for ron
desantis in any case
there is the possibility of ticket
splitting even if trump were to lose
this is not conceding trump is going to
lose the election and she's recognizing
the political realities on the ground
which is a lot of very tight senate
races and in by polling numbers a lot
tighter than the presidential race at
this point and the amy coney barrett
hearings
could have some impact on that because
you do have some swing state senators
who are
involved in the amy coney barrett
hearings like right now if you look at
the senate statistics
steve daines has picked up some ground
he was down a little bit to
bullock in in montana he now looks like
he is in the lead
in the north carolina race the the
democrat cal cunningham has been hit
with a sex scandal
there are not a lot of great polls that
are out right now
there's there's one poll that came out i
guess in the last week
and that one had cunningh cunningham up
fairly solidly over tom tillis
but again i expect that one to draw a
lot closer lindsey graham was suspected
to be running dead even
there's a new pull out today showing
lindsey graham up fairly substantially
those senate races matter an awful lot
so right now i'm telling you if you're a
republican
and you have to choose you don't have to
choose but if you have to choose whether
to give your money
to the presidential race or whether to
give your money to your senate candidate
truly it's it's the safe bet
it is the safer bet giving your money to
the senate candidate again that's not
conceding the presidential race that is
just being a political realist
about the necessity of republicans
retaining the senate because if
democrats pick up the senate they're
going to go for broke they're going to
break the filibuster that is no question
they're probably going to add states and
they've talked about court packing even
if they only do the first two
it wrecks the balance of power in the
american government
and leads to nothing but running room
for democrats in the future
if you're going to target where you're
giving right now i would say you got to
give to joni ernst in iowa
because right now her opponent theresa
greenfield is up by about four points
in most of these polls but that is a
very very close race
i would say that you you have to give to
tom tillis
in north carolina i would say that you
should take a serious look at giving to
susan collins i know if you're a
republican you got problems with susan
collins remember
if it were not for susan collins brett
kavanaugh would not be on the supreme
court
and losing that seat to sarah gideon
would be a real disaster area
right now that race is tight as a tick
extremely tight like within one point
tight
so go give to susan collins as much as
you have problems with susan collins
okay it is necessary that republicans
maintain the senate if you are
in fact a republican obviously
the other races that look fairly close
right now colorado is not
really inside margin of error but
there's not been a ton of polling that
has been done there
and uh and john hickenlooper who's a
very scandal-ridden candidate
uh he has yet to break 50 so those are
those are the races that i would be
focusing on
and again the amy county bear hearings
could make a difference there if
republicans put in a strong showing in
some of these swing states if you want
to go for by the way if you want to go
for a great candidate who's running an
extraordinarily competitive race in a
very bad year for republicans in his
state
john james in michigan is a stud john
james is running
a one-point race right now he's running
a one-point race with gary peters
in in michigan which is truly an amazing
feat okay
he ran last time he lost by a little bit
if trump somehow loses michigan and
james wins the seat in michigan
good for john james that's pretty
incredible okay so that's where things
stand now to the amy coney barrett
hearings
as we say it turns out the democrats
don't have a great comeback for amy
coney barrett because it turns out that
she is witty she is charming and she
knows what she's doing
she's been qualified as well qualified
by the american bar association
which is a designation i don't really
take super seriously because frankly i
think the american bar association
um is a is a leftist outlet and it has
been for quite a long time
nonetheless democrats have struggled for
a response to amy coney barrett
in a way that they they struggled with
brett kavanaugh before the fake rape
allegations
by all available evidence against
justice brett kavanaugh
so again narrative number one is that
amy coney barrett is uh is a religious
bigot
this is why you saw amy connor
protesters dressed up as the handmaid's
tale
i don't like read another book or watch
another show
this is it's just it's so ridiculous
first of all
it is hilarious to me that these people
are reduced to cosplaying
the uh cosplaying handmaid's tale so
here they were outside
uh wearing their handmaid's tale outfits
by the way overrated book wildly
overrated book okay but
here's the real question does any coney
bear look like something out of the
handmaid's tale to you
if so it's probably because you've lost
your mind so here was amy coney barrett
yesterday in her opening statement
and she was talking about the importance
of her family which apparently is very
bad
it's bad when republicans talk about the
importance of their family it shows that
they are
merely members of religious cults here's
amy coney bear talking about her family
as i said when i was nominated to serve
as a justice
i'm used to being in a group of nine my
family
nothing is more important to me and i'm
very proud to have them behind me
my husband jesse and i have been married
for 21 years
he has been a selfless and wonderful
partner every step of the way
okay so this means of course that she's
a subservient woman that's how that
works
that her husband has been supportive of
her all the way up to the 7th circuit
court of appeals and now to the supreme
court she talked about her philosophy
of government and this frankly is music
to the ears of an originalist
like me i mean i have long said that the
job of the court
is to interpret the law as closely as
possible
to the verbiage of the law that is the
as it was meant at the time that is the
that is what judges are tasked to do and
she backs that up here
courts are not designed to solve every
problem
or right every wrong in our public life
the policy decisions and value judgments
of government
must be made by the political branches
elected by and accountable to the people
the public should not expect courts to
do so and courts
should not try okay so first of all i
think it's important to note here this
is the precise opposite of what people
on the left
claim about amy coney barrett and about
every conservative justice
so every conservative justice that i
know of has said exactly this that there
is a
unique role for the courts the courts
are designed to interpret the law
as written and then enforce the law as
written and then the executive branch
does the actual hardcore enforcement
right that is what the courts are
designed to do
the left says that the right wants to
use the courts
in order to enforce their own moral
opinions their own theocracy that is
blatantly false
and the way you can tell this is
blatantly false is there's actual
statistical
evidence of this ilya shapiro over a
cato institute has done
actual statistical studies of how often
you see
textualist and originalist judges
writing dissents and also crossing the
aisle
on issues on which they disagree take a
perfect example justice scalia
famously ruled in a couple of different
cases on principles where he personally
disagreed
but he recognized it was not the job of
the judiciary to to
do his personal bidding right those two
examples that come to mind there are
many of them two of those examples that
come to mind
were justice scalia's opinion uh in in
the flag burning case
in which obviously very much against
flag burning nonetheless ruled
that the first amendment protected flag
burning as expressive speech
and also there was a case in which
justice scalia
took a similarly free speech opinion on
larry flint running a disgusting cartoon
about jerry falwell
shtupping his mother in an outhouse and
he said as much as i don't like this
cartoon
this is all protected first amendment
stuff and and the standard for
defamation of a public figure was
incredibly high right
you can see that from conservative
justices all the time right even
justices who i think are not going the
full david suiter and just deciding to
become
members of the hardcore left people like
justice gorsuch who have been pretty
good
throughout even they will sometimes
wander off their their own political
opinion or off their priors
and cross the aisle and vote with
democrats ruth bader ginsburg never did
that i mean she voted directly down the
line this is why when people say
that conservatives very often don't get
what they want from the justices they
appoint that's because
justices very often are not doing
political bidding if they are of the
right
they recognize that the political
branches are not the same as the
judicial branch so when amy coney
barrett says
listen my job is not to enforce morality
my job is to enforce the law
that is precisely the opposite of what
her political opponents suggest about
her
recognize that the true theocrats are
the people who treat leftism as a
religion then expect the courts
to be the rabbinate of the entire system
that the priesthood of the entire system
the priestly case of the entire system
amy coney bear continued along these
lines she said that courts have a vital
responsibility
to the rule of law which of course is
true there's a tendency in our
profession
to treat the practice of law as
all-consuming
while losing sight of everything else
but that makes for a shallow and
unfulfilling life
i worked hard as a lawyer and as a
professor
i owed that to my clients to my students
and to myself
but i never let the law define my
identity or crowd out the rest of my
life
a similar principle applies to the role
of courts
courts have a vital responsibility to
the rule of law which is critical to a
free
society okay that's of course exactly
right one of the things i like about amy
coney barrett is that she says that
courts have a role
again for conservatives government has a
role courts have a role legislators have
a role
in the view of the left everything is
political nobody has a role it's just a
question of
how you get things done right this is
whenever i hear a politician say i'm a
pragmatist
i start to shudder left or right because
once you say you're a pragmatist it
means you don't care about institutions
and you don't care about systems and if
you don't care about systems what that
really means
is that your core philosophy is power it
is not protection of individual
rights okay so democrats haven't come
back for any of us and so amy coney
barrett again well qualified nominee
she's going to sail through she'll be
confirmed next week
democrats have no comeback for this so
they've decided that their comeback is
it's unfair
they cry right it's just one long
crazy person scream after trump's
election in 2016 the the crazy lady
screaming at the sky the ah
that was what democrats response was to
all of this so kamala harris
who i i mean it's just unbelievable to
me that this lady is going to end up as
vice president of the united states
possibly she is awful in every way awful
i mean she is she is manipulative she is
terrible she is a damned liar
and the fact that there are people on
the left who actually like her is
astonishing to me considering how
dishonest she is
i have a lot of sympathy for bernie
sanders left she looks at kamala harris
and they say
this lady's just she
she really she's bad i mean there are
many women inside the democratic party
who are not this right amy klobuchar
would have been a much better pick
for joe biden but again biden thought
that he had to please the intersectional
base of the democratic party
we'll get to kamala harris and her take
on the amy coney barrett nomination
in just one second first let's talk
about how you protect your home so i'm
deeply concerned about security i've
always been
deeply concerned about my security but
not just about my security i want to
make sure that i can keep an eye on my
kids
thank god we have a nice house but that
means that there's a lot of room for my
kids to run around
and if you have young kids you know
they're little suicide machines all they
want to do is run into things and hurt
themselves
and you really first find out about it
when there's a giant scream unless you
have ring in which case you're sitting
in the kitchen and you're eating your
breakfast
and you can keep an eye on the kids as
they as they about as they prepare to
impale themselves on any sharp object
around the house you can go stop them i
love the ring devices around our home
whatever you call home ring has
everything you need to protect it you
can see and speak to whoever is at your
door from anywhere with video doorbells
you can keep an eye on every corner of
your house
with easy to install indoor and outdoor
cams you can protect your whole home
with ring alarm a powerful affordable
whole home security system you can
easily
install yourself get a special offer on
the ring welcome kit at ring.com
ben comes with that video doorbell three
and the time pro it's the perfect way to
start your ring experience plus
free two-day shipping go to is ring.com
and go check them out right now that is
a great offer special offer when you go
to ring.com for a special offer on the
ring welcome kit plus
free two-day shipping okay so democrats
they they have to respond to amy coney
bear's nomination so kamal o'hara says
that
the will of the people is being defied
which is weird because the will of the
people put donald trump
at least in electoral terms in the white
house now i understand everybody with
the popular vote and this
that's not how the process works the
process works how the process works the
will of the people has put the people
in positions to vote who are now in the
positions to vote according to the
american system of government but kamal
o'hara says the will of the people will
not be done if amy coney barrett
fills ruth bader ginsburg's slot now
what's amazing to me in all of this
is it is incredible how politicians and
uh members of our
government avoid responsibility there's
really only one person to blame for the
fact that donald trump
is going to replace ruth bader ginsburg
with amy coney barrett
that person's name is ruth bader
ginsburg ruth bader ginsburg
died in her mid-80s she'd been sick
since 2009. she could have stepped down
any time during the obama administration
there were people encouraging her to do
so
she thought hillary clinton was a
sure-fire winner and therefore she stuck
around
in fact she told people in the
democratic party who would you rather
have on the court than me
the answer from the democratic party of
course was somebody who thinks like you
but 30 years younger
but nonetheless this is all the evils of
the trump administration for filling a
seat that came open
again it came open through through
chance and circumstance and and fate
that's just the way this works but
here's kamal o'hara suggesting it's very
bad to fill the seat
more than 9 million americans have
already voted and millions more
will vote while this illegitimate
committee process
is underway a clear majority of
americans
want whomever wins this election to fill
the seat
and my republican colleagues know that
yet
they are deliberately defying the will
of the people
in their attempt to roll back the rights
and protections
provided under the affordable care act
okay i'm sorry this is just first of all
the evidence that she's gonna overturn
the aca
is nil there's one law school essay in
which she points out that john roberts
decision in the aca case is wrong that's
true
it is wrong okay it also happens to be
that they're not going to overturn the
aca case it was decided years ago
and it would be rejected on an appeal to
the supreme court because the case has
already been decided it was decided
not very long ago the notion that she is
going to simply overturn
the entire aca on the basis of the fact
that john roberts sort of crappy opinion
in the first
obamacare case it's just not true
democrats are pushing this lie anyway
okay and then you get cory booker who
and you gotta love
mr potato head over here he didn't just
bring his angry eyes he brought his
concerned eyes
and um and cory booker if there's one
person who can make kamala harris look
not rehearsed it is it is cory booker he
makes her look spontaneous and joyous
cory booker is the most rehearsed
politician i have ever seen in my entire
life
he is perhaps the most irritating
politician about i mean and i watch
politicians for a living
this dude is as irritating as itching
powder in your eyes i mean this guy
is just nails on a chalkboard irritating
here is
cory booker who is very upset that a
vote is even going to be held on amy
coney bear you can tell he's upset
because he uses both his upset eyes he
brought his angry eyes
he takes out his upset eyes pops him in
blinks a lot
very upset cory booker and then he just
repeats things over and over
he repeats beetlejuice until michael
keaton randomly appears
in the well of the senate here was uh
cory booker being obnoxious
what is going on in america today in the
midst of a deadly pandemic in an ongoing
election having a rushed supreme court
nomination hearing is not normal
and we cannot normalize it people are
voting right now the american people
should decide
the american people should decide the
american people
should decide
i will not be voting to confirm judge
barrett's nomination
okay either cory booker is the most
emotional person who's ever been in
american politics or he's completely
unemotional and he's kind of a sociopath
and uh and i sort of feel like the
latter because every time i'm so
upset the american people should decide
tinkerbell should live
amy coney barrett shouldn't be on the
court clap until tinkerbell lives cory
clap clap spartacus
clap it's a spartacus moment
tinkerbell's living we're doing it
yeah it's not happening amy coney
barrett is going to the court so uh
congratulations
corey booker meanwhile dick durbin is
saying that it is
it is a self-serving proposal this is
the senator from illinois
who again once called american soldiers
akin to pol pot i remember this
uh senator durbin says it's self-serving
for republicans to fill the seat after
all they didn't fill the seat with
merrick garland
yes because they weren't going to vote
for merrick garland because they
disagree with his judicial philosophy
senator durbin here's durbin again doing
this routine we can't win the vote so
there shouldn't be a vote
people had already begun casting votes
and my republican colleagues marched in
front of the cameras
looked down at their shoes dutifully
reversed their positions
and lined up obediently behind their
leader again
gets down to this if the american people
do get an election year voice regarding
a vacancy on the supreme court or they
don't
in 2016 senator mcconnell said give them
a voice
now he says don't give them voice it is
a shameless
self-serving venal reversal okay um
just a note it's also a shameless
self-serving venal reversal that you all
said that merrick garland should get a
vote now you say that amy coney barry
should should not
pat leahy most famous for having a cameo
in uh the in the batman movies
i heard senator leahy from vermont
saying the same thing they're breaking
their word they're breaking you guys are
pledging to
to pack the supreme court guys and kill
the filibuster i think that them
quote unquote breaking their they didn't
give their word that they were not going
to vote on a republican nominee they
said when the parties are controlled
parties control different branches in an
election year then you should wait for
that to be decided by the american
public i think it's a dumb principle i
don't think you have to vote on anybody
you don't want to you're the senate of
the united states
but democrats are trying to hang their
head on this
we shouldn't be holding a hearing three
weeks from a presidential election
when millions of americans have already
voted
now when doing so requires that
literally half of the senate
goes back on their word think of that by
republican colleagues literally half of
the senate
had to break their word contradicting
every
argument they made four years ago about
the american people
needing a voice during election year
vacancies
okay so screaming at the sky and whining
about a perfectly traditional process
again
there have been more than a dozen i
think the statistic was close to 20
people who have been nominated during an
election year and usually when the
parties
control the same branches they when they
control the executive and the
legislature the person gets confirmed
when a different party controls the
legislature from the presidency they do
not get confirmed it is that simple okay
in just a second we'll get to the more
substantive critiques of amy coney
barrett and as we will see
not good critiques there either we'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that right now
if you ran up a credit card bill now is
a terrible time to have a credit card
bill that you have run up because
then you start getting those huge
interest rate charges and you can really
i mean i know people
who've fallen into credit card debt and
it is a disaster area you start getting
those month-on-month enormous fees
and now you're paying more interest than
you are on the principal and it just
keeps accruing if you don't pay it
it's really really a bad situation you
need to get out of it if you're a
responsible actor this is why you should
check out lightstream
lightstream offers credit card
consolidation loans from 5.95
apr with auto pay and excellent credit
the rate is fixed so it's not going to
go up over the life of the loan the
application is 100
online you don't even have to leave your
house to apply you can get a loan from 5
000 bucks to 100 000 bucks there are
absolutely no fees
you can get your funds as soon as the
day you apply lightstream believes
people with good credit deserve a better
loan experience that's exactly what they
deliver people love it lightstream
customers know that they are saving
not only time and money but maybe their
financial future my listeners can save
even more with an additional
interest rate discount the only way to
get that discount is to go to
lightstream.com
shapiro that's l-i-g-h-t s-t-r-e-a-m dot
com slash apparel lightstream.com
shapiro go check them out right now
subject to credit approval rate includes
0.50 auto pay discount low strike
requires excellent credit terms and
conditions apply officers are subject to
change that notice
visit lightstream.com shapiro for more
information
always like doing the announcery voice
at the very end right there alrighty so
the democrats then have to they have a
second line of attack so first line of
attack
is we shouldn't hold this vote because
votes are mean second line of attack is
we are afraid that amy coney barrett is
going to do exactly what she pledges to
do and rule in accordance with the
constitution
and as we all just want ruth bader
ginsburg now
note if you are a political actor
this so kamala harris
she put up she she did this from home
and
she put up a a book
a children's book of ruth bader ginsburg
behind her as she made the speech she
shifted this out a couple of times right
she had this little prop stand behind
her
and says i descent ruth bader ginsburg
makes her mark as she makes the case
that apparently the ruth bader ginsburg
occupied seat should be occupied by
apparently children of ruth bader
ginsburg
or descendants of ruth better ginsburg
from now into perpetuity it should be
just like a communist country
in communist countries judges appoint
their own successors apparently the same
where the party does
the same thing should happen obviously
with ruth bader ginsburg now
i just want to know something gator ruth
bader ginsburg
she may be a great feminist hero she was
not a good justice
i know it's impolitic to point this out
at this point her judgments stink
okay in controversial cases she wrote
opinions that were completely removed
from the constitution in every area
except for civil procedure civil
procedure
oddly enough she's actually an expert on
and she would actually rule
in interesting and uh and textualist
ways she would actually try to fulfill
the mandate of a judge when it came to
civil procedure when it came to
everything socially related
she literally just looked into her heart
found the answer and then twisted the
constitution to fit it she was a bad
justice
she voted on every single social case
the same way that kamala harris would
if you vote like a senator and you're on
the court you're not a good judge that
is a good way to tell whether somebody's
a good judge would they vote exactly the
same way
on the court as they would as a senator
and if the answer is yes then you don't
know the difference between the
political branches of government and the
judicial branch of government
but kamala harris makes the case that
acb is going to be real bad because
acb is not rbg and rbg's seat should
remain for rbg and not for acb
and then she just throws in a reference
to the notorious bij for fun here's
kamala harris
justice ruth bader ginsburg devoted her
life
to fight for equal justice and she
defended the constitution but now
her legacy and the rights she fought so
hard to protect
are in jeopardy by replacing
justice ruth bader ginsburg with someone
who will
undo her legacy president trump is
attempting to roll back
americans rights for decades to come
oh the what are those rights that we're
talking about she gets more specific
the rights that she's talking about here
are roe versus wade right abortion
and uh and the and rights on
quote-unquote obamacare which is not a
right
okay that is a that is a privilege
granted by government it is an
entitlement
granted by government and this is what
hera said it's been interesting actually
to watch
as the democrats shy away from roe v
wade talk so you would think
that most of their attack would be on on
amy coney barrett and roe versus wade
because the polling tends to show that
americans are somewhere between pro-life
and pro-choice meaning they don't buy
into the democrats crazy position they
should be able to abort a baby all the
way to point of birth
and uh depending on for the governor of
virginia maybe a little later than that
uh and they also disagree with the
full-on pro-life position i mean this is
just what polls show they disagree with
my own position
which is that abortion should be banned
from point of conception
i have a feeling that will change over
time as the science of uh of embryology
gets stronger to the point where you can
actually see inside the womb with more
clarity
from the point of conception this this
is what keeps happening as the american
public keeps moving back toward
conception
the date on which they think abortion is
okay it used to be they thought it was
like
six months in now it's looking more and
more like the last couple of trimesters
americans are getting uncomfortable with
which
of course they should be because it
looks like a baby by the time you're
already at week nine week ten it's
starting to look
like a baby just a very very tiny baby
in any case the democrats have decided
to shy away from the abortion issue
because they've progressively been
losing on that issue because of the
science and instead they're focusing in
on the possibility that acb is going to
rule to to get rid of obamacare that's
not going to happen
again that's not going to happen but
kamala harris tweeted out november 10th
that's when the u.s supreme court is set
to hear a case to strike down the
affordable care act
senate republicans are fast tracking
this nominee today in order to ensure
that happens yes i'm sure they're doing
it with an eye toward
what is widely perceived to be a rather
fringe case on
obamacare i'm sure that that's exactly
what they're doing they're not
fast-tracking the nominee to get it in
before the election they're doing it so
that she can rule on the obamacare case
sure sure okay cory booker again
my least favorite american senator i
don't know there are a few competitors
he's up there maisie hirono is awful
but booker is ugh i can't say enough
words about booker he is uh he is as
artificial
as the mr potato head he appears to
emulate and here is cory booker
saying that roe versus wade and
obamacare are the will of the american
people so a couple things one
even if you want to make the case that
obamacare is the will of the american
people because elected branches voted
for it
i mean i guess you could make that case
that's fair although the repudiation
right after obamacare was pretty staunch
against the democrats roe vs wade was
never the will of the american people
the american people didn't vote for roe
versus wade roe vs wade was a complete
judicial usurpation of the political
function of the government
roe vs wade was the federal government
deciding that the constitution of the
united states suddenly mandated
tolerance for abortion
past the before point of viability
and it has like nothing to do with the
constitution and it was a usurpation of
state power and it was used for patient
of legislative power even if you wanted
to do it
at the federal level but cory booker see
here's the thing
too many democrats believe in the
russoian will of the people namely if
if something i like happens it's because
it was the will of the people if
something i don't like happens it's
because it was not the will of the
people so the same democrats who say
that obamacare was the will of the
people
because the elected branches did it say
that amy coney barrett should not be on
the court because the will of the people
disagree in other words the will of the
people as a phrase
sounds suspiciously like i agree with it
to democrats so here is cory booker
saying that everything he agrees with is
the will of the people
we're here because in the middle of a
deadly pandemic
in the middle of an ongoing election
senate republicans have found
a nominee in judge barrett who they know
will do what they couldn't do subvert
the will
of the american people and overturn the
aca and overturn roe v
wade that's what this is about that's
why we're here it's very
simple senate republicans know the
american people don't want this
but they don't care okay that's not even
true by polling data plurality of
americans are totally fine
with acb being nominated then you get
pat leahy who's here to explain that a
catholic mother of seven uh one of the
most powerful females
will be in america and in american
history uh palais he says that she will
be harmful to women
yes i definitely trust pat leahy and
what's harmful to women
they're scared judge barrett they're
scared that your confirmation would rip
from them to very
healthcare protections the millions of
americans
have ought to maintain and which
congress has repeatedly
rejected lemonade they're scared that
the clock
will be turned back to a time when women
had no right to control their own bodies
and when it was acceptable to
discriminate against women
in the workplace okay if women are
scared of that it's because um they've
been misinformed by by democrats and
women who are scared of it
are uninformed and we are not living in
a world
where abortion is on the menu in terms
of banning abortion wholesale as much as
pro-lifers like me would love to protect
every unborn life
it is a state issue it will remain a
state issue even if roe versus wade were
to be discarded
it is just as simple as that and when he
says that women are afraid that they're
going to be
forced from the work like what that
discriminated against in the workplace
like what the hell is he talking about
discrimination against the workplace is
federal discrimination in the workplace
against women is federally illegal under
title ix of the civil rights act what
the hell is he talking about
it's just i'm sorry the democrats case
is absurd meanwhile
republicans are reveling in their chance
to actually talk about the constitution
lindsey graham who's now opened up
uh a rather substantial lead like a
six-point lead in south carolina
according to the latest polling data he
was running dead even until a moment ago
he's getting a chance to uh to be
lindsey graham 2.0 in this hearing
lindsey graham's best moments
have been in judiciary hearings she's
great during the brett kavanaugh
hearings he was good yesterday here with
senator graham
talking about our constitutional duty
the bottom line is justice ginsburg when
asked about this several years ago
said that a president serves four years
not three
there's nothing unconstitutional about
this process
this is a vacancy that's occurred
through a tragic loss of a great woman
and we're going to fill that vacancy
with another great woman
the bottom line here is that the senate
is doing its duty
constitutionally okay that of course is
true ted cruz points out correctly
that the democrats see the judiciary as
a policy-making body they do not see it
as a as a body designed to interpret the
law of course this is true
democrats and republicans have
fundamentally different visions
of the court of what the supreme court
is supposed supposed to do
what its function is
democratic senators view the court as a
super legislature
as a policy-making body as a body that
will decree
outcomes to the american people
now that vision of the court is
something found nowhere in the
constitution
and it's a curious way to want to run a
country
okay that of course is exactly right but
you know what it doesn't really
doesn't really matter all that much
because democrats are going to continue
to run the country
that way whatever tool is at their
disposal they will use but democrats are
being pretty careful here i mean
acknowledge this the democrats are being
pretty careful
so far in their questioning of amy coney
barrett they do not want to repeat the
debacle of the kavanaugh hearing that
actually redounded
against them in pretty significant ways
okay in just a second we're going to get
to
the other aspect of the supreme court
hearing which is the looming specter of
court packing we'll get to that in just
one second first
we've all heard the stories in the news
a good guy uses a gun to protect his
family from criminals and then he gets
arrested
the legal system very often is not fair
there are political pressures that are
brought to bear on local da's to bring
charges against people who defend
themselves what does this mean it means
that you know law abiding citizens not
only should own firearms they should
know their legal rights they should know
how to use them and they should have the
defense
at their disposal that they require
legally if god forbid they have to use a
gun
in order to protect their own lives in
order to protect their property legally
speaking
well there's a way you can take a simple
and powerful journey to firearms and
self-defense confidence it is called the
complete concealed carry and family
defense guide
from the us concealed carry association
the uscca it is 100
free you'll learn how to detect
attackers before they see you how to
survive a mass shooting the safest and
most dangerous places to sit in a
restaurant how to responsibly own and
store a gun
especially if you have little kids and a
whole lot more it's 164 pages it comes
with a bonus audio version so you can
listen
whenever you want the second amendment
is deeply important
knowing your own right is really
important and knowing how to properly
exercise those rights
even more important just text ben to 87
222 you'll get instant
access and the chance to win a thousand
bucks so you can buy a gun to protect
your family which is a great opportunity
text ben to 87 222 right now and get
involved with my friend
over at the uscca again that's ben text
it to 87
222 right now to get that free concealed
carry and family defense guide okay
we'll get to
the democrats constant refusal to sound
off on court packing
and just one second first it's baseball
season
it is the old glory daily wire baseball
bat it's back
it's patriotic and it's fantastic this
is our limited edition handcrafted
custom painted baseball bat emblazoned
with that magical daily wire logo
when we first put this bad out in a
numbered edition a few months ago it
sold out in 48 hours that was only when
it was available to our all access
members
now anyone the common man can purchase
it but inventory is still limited so get
yours before they are gone
text the keyword baseball to 83 400 to
purchase
your bat today again text keyword
baseball to 83 400
and you can purchase your daily wire old
glory baseball bat it's pretty fantastic
and if you haven't already head on over
to dailywear.com subscribe right now
become an all-access member that gets
you access to all of our daily content
the sunday special
one day earlier and this right here the
greatest of all beverage vessels that
leftist tears tumbler
go check it out right now it overfloweth
these days we'll see how much this thing
fills
in the future you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay and then we uh we get to the
democrats final response to amy coney
barrett and that is maybe we'll pack the
court
right this is them i i don't think it's
real i mean i'll just be frank with you
i do not think the democrats really
intend
on packing the court because if they did
pack the court then
the political response from the other
side would be packed to court
the other way i mean it would completely
trash the institution but i think that
they feel
it necessary to offer a glimpse of hope
to their own base this is why joe biden
is playing footsie with it
so biden yesterday was actually asked
again about it and he said he's kind of
uncomfortable with chord packing but he
refused to come out and just condem it
outright
naturally the other democrats are trying
to dodge the question as well tim kaine
former vice presidential candidate with
hillary clinton and senator from
virginia he was asked
about biden and court packing he said
biden doesn't have to answer those
questions
he doesn't naturally the good news is
that members of the media will never
actually hold democrats to account for
this and i don't even know the members
of the public hear that don't care that
much
why won't he answer that question
well i haven't asked him but i have a
pretty good idea bill because it's not
his business
the constitution gives no power to the
president or vice president to
pack the court i heard senator ernst say
joe needs to say he won't pack the court
it's not a presidential responsibility
congress according to article one of the
constitution
sets the composition you haven't heard
joe biden said he would send a plan to
the court i don't think this is a matter
for the president at all
okay that's a lie it would have to be
approved by the president he could veto
the bill
and there are certain things that the
president is not required to get
involved with
for example getting rid of the
filibuster asking biden about getting
rid of the filibuster
he's the president you know if he gets
elected and so he actually has no say in
that might he could tell his party not
to do it
but the president doesn't actually have
a role in that it's a senate procedural
move when it comes to court packing
there'd have to be a bill signed by the
president so of course tim kaine
is just lying there mazie hirono the
dumbest person in the united states
senate
cory booker's the most irritating messy
hirono is probably the dumbest uh she
dodged on court packing yesterday as
well
i have been thinking about court reform
for a number of years
but we don't have have a serious
discussion about core reform which by
the way it will take serious discussion
it's just
not a matter of do you want this change
do you want that change
that kind of discussion doesn't happen
on this so the democrats take back the
senate
and yes i expect joe biden and kampala
howard to be laser focused
on the potential for this country
to give this out of control president
chaotic president another four years
that is exactly what they ought to be
focusing on okay so we're not going to
answer any of these tough questions
naturally the entire democratic
commentariat
is now pushing court expansion eugene
robinson the columnist for the
washington post he has a piece today
called republicans are trying to make
court expansion a mortal sin
don't let them saying ask them again if
and when biden is president and
democrats control both houses of
congress
whether they'll pack the court then and
only then will biden's view on expanding
the number of supreme court justices be
meaningful
because then and only then will court
packing be an actual possibility that is
the dumbest argument i have ever heard
in my life
so you can only ask a politician about
what they're going to do once they've
been elected because only then do they
have the capacity to do it
that is directly counter to how
democracies or republics work
if you're going to vote for a candidate
typically you're allowed to ask them
what they're going to do when they get
the power
that's absurd but says eugene robinson
they should actually manipulate the
court
he says there's more than one way to
skew or unskew the ideology of the high
court by manipulating
the number of sitting justices you could
do it effectively by reducing the number
of seats to eight
keeping once he'd vacant for more than a
year as republicans did with barack
obama's nominee
in 2016. they didn't do that to keep the
seat open and not not so that there
could be eight justices they didn't care
about their being eight justices
if barack obama had nominated someone
whose judicial philosophy they liked
presumably they would have
gone along with it or he could rush
through a hasty confirmation process as
eugene robinson but
you could also just pack the
constitution if democrats were to win
the white house and senate and keep
control of the house
they would have options for how to
respond to the long republican campaign
to capture the courts
and the shenanigans they've used to
pursue it expanding the size of the
supreme court wouldn't be their only
option okay recognize something about
the courts
every single norm that has been broken
around the courts was first broken by
democrats
it was democrats who broke the norm
around approving qualified judicial
nominees
by borking robert bork it was democrats
who broke the norm
surrounding judicial nominees and
treating them with respect during the
clarence thomas hearings and then again
during the brett kavanaugh hearings it
was democrats who decided to nuke the
judicial filibuster
under barack obama so let's be
clear here everything republicans have
done they've done because democrats set
the precedent
it is not because republicans set the
precedent but in any case all of this
i think is uh all of this may be
really a moot point you know maybe we're
putting too much focus on the court
packing thing
and i say that as someone who cares
deeply about court packing why because
it's just one aspect of a simple fact
which is that joe biden
will not be asked any tough questions
from now until the election joe biden is
not a coherent person
he's not and asking him to be coherent
is a mistake he's a doddering old fool
he's been a fool for a while but now
he's doddering and old as well
he cannot string together a sentence
this is why it was such a
an active political error for president
trump to keep interrupting him during
that first debate by the way if you look
at the polling data
and i know i know every time i cite
polls people start screaming at their
at their phones and their radios okay
guys data is data if you look at the
polling data the closest that trump
and biden have been was september 29th
then the polls diverge
they split biden goes almost straight up
and trump goes almost straight down
starting september 29th what happened
september 29th
that first debate why because people
wanted to see if joe biden could hold up
and all joe biden had to do a stand
there let the guy talk
i think that frankly if if it requires a
zoom debate in order for
in order for biden to be allowed to talk
then do the zoom debate more biden
speaking on camera is better
biden speaking on camera in any
situation where his being asked his
tough question is bad
for joe biden in fact joe biden is such
a terrible i mean he's a terrible
candidate he is
this is why i've said before that if
trump look if any republican losing to a
democrat
republicans face a bunch of
institutional obstacles namely the media
who hate their guts and will cover them
negatively well well carrying around a
slop bucket for the democratic candidate
they have to face the institutional
biases of some members of the of the
government
they have to like there are certain
obstacles that republicans just have to
face as candidates that's true but if
you lose to joe biden by double digits
this old daughtering idiot you lose to
this guy who ran for president 1 million
times and lost every time until now
then some of that has to be on your own
campaign strategy because biden cannot
hold it together
he's not capable of holding it together
so for example
yesterday joe biden was asked
specifically about a gallup poll it
showed 56
of americans were happier now than they
were four years ago
and he was asked what do you say to
those people who say they were happier
now than four years ago about why they
should vote for you
and biden literally said they shouldn't
vote for me the poll says 56
dude do you not understand how numbers
work that's that's a pretty amazing
amazing statement here was joe biden
saying just that gallup reported
last week 50 56 of americans said that
they were better off today
than they were four years ago would have
been under the obama binding
administration
so why should people who feel that they
are better off today
under the trump administration vote for
you well if they think that they
probably shouldn't
but that was not the only joe biden
fumble and stumble like this should be
the story of the campaign
and the story of the campaign should be
that this guy is not going to be
president for long if he is president he
needs to get a food taster first of all
for kamala harris
never let kamala serve ut but beyond
that
this is not a person who's gonna be
president in in four years let alone
eight years
okay here is joe biden stumbling once
again and saying he was running for
senate of the united states
you know we have to come together that's
why i'm running
i'm running as a proud democrat for the
senate
well no no you're you're not though so
there's that
and then uh biden also forgot mitt
romney's name he only ran against
the romney campaign in 2012. okay this
is not like 40 years ago
and he's mixing up senators or something
here he was forgetting romney's name and
calling him the mormon guy
you may remember i got in trouble when
we're running against
the senator who was a mormon the
governor
okay okay like well done well done joe
biden he is not coherent he is not with
it so maybe we shouldn't put too much
focus on the fact he won't answer
questions on court packing
i'm not sure he's capable of answering
serious questions on anything
the bar is so low for him at this point
that if he is even
mildly in the same ballpark as a topic
people credit him
with with doing a great job as he did
during that cnn town hall
but this is why trump pressuring him and
then letting him talk would be the good
strategy
from here on out by the way that tactic
does work so mitch mcconnell the senate
majority leader he is running against
amy mcgrath in kentucky he's going to
beat amy mcgrath again democrats have
poured money down a rat hole running
against mitch mcconnell in kentucky
i i feel it's necessary to spend an
awful lot of time
or as much time as possible with
republicans who are capable of
articulating
conservative principles and pointing out
that democrats stand against a lot of
the major institutions of american
government that's why i spent a lot of
time
on that pence harris debate where i said
like if you strip the trumpian
attitude from the trump administration
all you get is
a lot of good policy and some
conservative ideology
it doesn't mean everything the trump
administration has done is good they've
spent out the wazoo for example but
articulation of conservative principle
in a in a solid way is a winner
here was mitch mcconnell going after amy
mcgrath in their senate race they had a
senate debate the other night
and uh and mcconnell just thoroughly
thoroughly trashed her
my opponent said she's the most
progressive person in kentucky what does
that mean
that means they want to stack the
supreme court in other words add numbers
so they can get an
outcome that they like she wants to make
the district of columbia state
puerto rico estate get rid of the
filibuster in the senate
in short there's not a dime's worth of
difference between my opponent and all
the national democrats
that you've watched if you give them
control of the government
that's what they'll do this is exactly
right this is why at the very least i'm
hopeful that republicans make that
argument
in senate races around the country again
it is looking much more competitive in
the senate races right now than it is
in the presidential race overall and as
i say if republicans hold maine if they
hold montana
if they hold georgia both seats in
georgia
if they if they somehow take michigan
if they hold the seat in iowa they'll
retain the senate and that will be a
very very important thing because again
democrats can control the presidency and
the house and the senate
is one of the scarier propositions on
the ballot so
if you're going to take that money and
donate it somewhere donate it to a
senate race because those things are
real close and the senate is going to
matter an
awful awful lot in coming years even if
trump wins it's going to matter an awful
lot trump wins
and democrats take the senate nothing's
getting done so
those senate races matter an awful lot
more focus on the senate less on the
presidential race
is my is my quick sort of political pick
for the day
okay meanwhile controversy has broken
out over covet once again
so couple things one there's supposed to
be a debate this week the commission on
presidential debate said they could not
have an in-person debate
well as it turns out president trump has
now tested negative for coronavirus on
consecutive days and is no longer
infectious to others
according to dr sean connelly he said in
a statement in response your inquiry
regarding the president's most recent
covenant 19 tests
i can share with you he has now tested
negative on consecutive days using the
abbott binax now antigen card
it is important to note this test was
not used in isolation for the
determination of the president's current
negative status repeatedly negative
antigen tests taken in context with
additional clinical and laboratory data
including viral load
subgenomic rna and pcr cycle threshold
measurements as well as ongoing
assessment of viral culture data
all indicate a lack of detectable
detectable viral replication
this comprehensive data in concert with
the cdc's guidelines for removal
of transmission-based precautions have
informed our medical team's assessment
the president is not in fact infectious
to others so that means that it has been
a mistake for the commission on a
presidential debate
to cancel the debate but no shock there
they stepped in just in time to save joe
biden
from a second debate okay meanwhile
trump out on the campaign trail in his
post-coveted state and things are
getting exciting out there
so president trump danced to ymca uh he
was down in florida
in sanford florida doing a big rally and
uh here was the president looking
enthused and healthy
and uh and ready to go it's hard not to
laugh because uh
listen the president's a funny guy so
here is president from dancing
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a that's a look it's a luck it's
a thing it's a thing that that has
happened in
in human history and then trump uh
obviously very excited to be back out on
the stump uh and he says he's gonna wade
into the crowd and kiss people some of
us actually predicted this right i said
that he was gonna body surf he's gonna
jump out into the crowd get carried
around on the shoulders
of various trump supporters uh he said
he was going to wander out there and
just kiss everybody
i went through it now they say i'm
immune i can feel i feel so powerful
i'll
walk into that audience i'll walk in
there i'll kiss everyone in that
audience
i'll kiss the guys and the beautiful
women and um
everybody i'll just give you a big fat
kiss
he's the funny man he does the funniest
that is that is for
that is for sure i i will say is it a
smart closing pitch is it a super smart
closing pitch well it shows that listen
americans are still worried about covet
i think that a lot of that worry is
overblown
not because of fears of code if you're
in a vulnerable sub-population
but because the death rates on covet
have dropped dramatically
dramatically from march i mean i would
actually hazard to say
that if trump had gotten kovid in march
when people didn't know what they were
doing there's a
much better chance that the man would
have died from it because that's true
for everybody in a vulnerable subgroup
right he had to take rem death severe
that was not available
in the early going he took monoclonal
antibodies those were not available in
the early goings
the hospitalization rates are down and
the death rates in hospitals are down by
something like 80 to 90 percent
so this thing is not nearly as deadly as
it was the first time
around with that said are americans
still fearful is a certain amount of
caution still merited absolutely
absolutely and that's why
again from a political point of view i
don't i really don't understand
why republican politicians particularly
are are being so cavalier
about the mask wearing listen i
understand that we live in a reactionary
era where whenever democrats in the
media say something is important the
immediate reaction is to say it's not
important at all
i understand that it's irritating to
watch members of the media saying
selectively
that certain masks are are useful and
certain masks are not that if you're
dancing for racial justice
in crowds or if you're going to a party
in a minority neighborhood
then mass scoring is not important but
if you're a jew going to shul
or if you're a trump rally or going to a
trump rally or if you're going to an acb
event then that is super super important
then the masks are super important
and the selective application of mask
shaming
is really irritating that doesn't mean
it is smart for american republican
politicians
to take off the mask and wade into
crowds because the minute they get
covered then the media is going to turn
around and say because you weren't
cautious
enough now there's no guarantee that
you're going to avoid covet even if you
wear a mask
there is a recent self-reported survey
saying that 85 of people
who said that they had gotten coveted
said that they frequently or often
wore masks now again that self-reported
data that may be a little bit high
nonetheless the the sort of perception
widespread among the american public
is that you're not being as cautious as
you could be if you are not wearing
masks i don't understand
by the way you know who understands this
mitch mcconnell right mitch mcconnell
was asked the other day about why he's
not visiting the white house so often he
said because they're not taking enough
precautions
on kova that is a widespread public
perception so trump's doing these big
outdoor rallies with a lot of people not
wearing masks
it doesn't make tons of sense to me
frankly it just like on a political
level
it doesn't make a lot of sense mark
meadows did some of this yesterday so
meadows was being quizzed
by the media and uh and he
wanted to take off his mask so he just
kind of wandered away
that way i can take this off the top
well i'm more than 10 feet away i'm not
well
i'm not going to talk through it next
okay so you heard one of the members of
the media say no don't take off the mess
and i'm more than 10 feet away that's
not all meadows fault obviously it's not
all of
meadows fault and that is the media's
fault for i mean really
like i get it it makes no scientific
sense but let's just be real about what
politics is
very often politics is the meme and
right now the meme is the match
democrats understand this for some
reason republicans
seem not to again i get it the media are
super irritating on the subject right
jim acosta was at a trump rally
yesterday
and people were chanting cnn sucks fact
check true and uh and then he started
saying that
you know getting coronavirus that also
sucks it's thank you jim acosta we
needed your
expert medical advice jim acosta uh and
ladies find you
a gentleman who loves you like jim costa
loves jim acosta
iowa north carolina are really states
that should be in the bag for president
trump right now
that's an indication as to how much
trouble he's in politically right now
wolf
and as this crowd is chanting that there
are members of the press here who suck
i should also point out wolf what also
sucks getting the coronavirus
um so thank you for that jim acosta yes
it turns out getting coronavirus does in
fact suck
and it still turns out that on the death
permian level democratic states still
have the most death so if you're turning
this into a political thing
let's recognize that that cuts uh a fair
number of ways now
this is broken out into a controversy in
which
trump finally then the media been trying
to get this to happen all along trump
was smart to avoid it for months now
it's breaking out into the open
he's having a direct conflict with dr
anthony fauci who again never should
have been propped up
as captain kovid right the guy who knows
more about kova than any other human
being
he was wrong about a lot of stuff early
on he said that it was not a real threat
you should go about your daily lives
and then he said that you should not
bother with masks because apparently he
was lying to the american people
in order that we wouldn't use ppe and we
would reserve it for medical workers
and then he was very much in favor of
lockdowns and now it turns out that
those lockdowns were not such a great
idea as the who
now recognizes in fact there's a
tremendous amount of rising covad in
europe
first of all we should not actually use
number of cases as a good indicator of
whether a country is handling this well
you shouldn't you should use
hospitalizations icus and deaths
as the indication of whether a country
is handling this particularly well
if you're going to use infections as the
as the gauge then you should
determine whether you're on the downside
of a curve or whether you're just in the
middle of a lockdown so sweden right now
has not really seen a tremendous
increase in the number of cases because
they've been open basically forever
but uk france they're seeing an absolute
skyrocketing number of cases right now
does that mean like the end of the world
apparently not apparently europe is is
staying open according to the washington
post
england has seen new coronavirus cases
quadruple in the past three weeks
now has more covenant 19 patients
hospitalized than before the government
imposed a lockdown
in march well i mean yes that that makes
perfect sense a lot of people are being
infected
like much of europe britain however is
pursuing targeted local restrictions
they're closing pubs in liverpool for
example
while doing everything it can to avoid
another national lockdown and closure of
schools
in a statement to parliament british
prime minister boris johnson said he was
trying to take a balanced approach
between the extremes of shuttering our
lives and our economy and abandoning the
fight he set up a three-tiered system
and this is common
across europe countries across europe
are similarly looking for compromises as
they scramble to contain a resurgence in
infections and hospital admissions even
still
they face more anger and frustration
from businesses and individuals than
they did
in the spring ravi gupta microbiologist
at the university of cambridge said that
in britain and other european countries
a full lockdown is off the political
agenda in part because the fear factor
around the coronavirus is not what it
was
in the spring he says it's clear people
cannot endure long-term restrictions
outside of authoritarian regimes
so this is not a great shock and it's
not restricted to the united states
what that does mean is that the the
lockdown skeptics
were correct lockdown has not in fact
been a big boon all it did was delay
this thing
maybe that had the effect of tamping
down the death rates in march and april
which is good
but it did not have the effect of
quashing the virus or stopping the virus
in any real way okay bottom line is this
in american politics you know come back
across the side of the water where
everybody pretends
that america exists in isolation the
trump administration policy as i've been
saying all along was not wrong
their policy was actually much better
than what a democratic administration
policy would have been which would have
been a fascistic top-down control over
every area of the american economy
which would have been really bad i mean
joe biden is basically threatening it
now
it would have been really bad however
there are two sides to this one is the
policy as always with the trump
administration one is the policy
and one is the messaging when it comes
to messaging you know it is a bad idea
to be at war with the with anthony fauci
who again has been propped up by the
media put on the cover of intouch
magazine
if trump wanted to put him front and
center originally then you can't always
be at war with
your own personnel so trump quoted
fauci in an ad in which fauci said that
i think that they've done more than
anybody else would have
basically showing that fauci himself was
a fan of the trump administration's
action then fauci
uh who is a political actor i mean he is
political to pretend he is not political
is to ignore his actions over the past
few months
he is political that does not mean that
targeting him is smart
fauci then went on cnn and said that
he's angry that there's a commercial
quoting him okay here's the deal dude if
you don't want to be in the media don't
be in the media if you are in the media
get ready for people to quote you in
commercials
so trump is not wrong to be angry at
fouchy that also does not mean it's
smart to go to war with voucher here is
fouchy going after trump yesterday
should the trump campaign take this ad
down
you know i think so jake i think it's
really unfortunate and
really disappointing that they did that
it's so clear that i'm not
a political person and i have never
either directly or indirectly
endorsed a political candidate and to
take a completely out of contact
statement and put it in which is
obviously a political campaign had i i
thought was really very disappointing
okay so there he is going after trump
by the way the statement was not really
out of context it really was not
and um and there's fouchy going after
trump he doesn't like trump it's pretty
obvious trump doesn't like him
in fact you did have to admit that trump
is right about being immune to the virus
at this point
the problem with the word immune it
means different things to different
individuals jake if he means
that he's been infected and having been
infected and recovered
that he will not get infected again
that's true
for a limited period of time what we do
not know
is how long that protection lasts so
technically speaking
the fact that he has recovered from an
immunological standpoint
he has an immune response in him that
very likely would protect him from being
reinfected okay well the media are
disappointed in this answer because
they've been proclaiming that trump is
lying when he says he's immune
okay but again here fauci is to pretend
he's not political
is is a mistake here is here's anthony
fauci suggesting
that he can't think of any reasons for
excess cova deaths except for
kovit now it is true that the excess
deaths year on year
are almost are largely attributable to
cove but it's also true we've seen
excess deaths
in terms of suicide and depression we've
seen deaths of despair
we have seen excess deaths in terms of
people who didn't go to the hospital and
they should have gone to the hospital
so there were excess deaths that were
attributable to lockdown
and it is unscientific it really is
for for fouchy not to at least
acknowledge that
do you think that this is a sign that we
are actually
under counting coronavirus deaths yeah
no you can't say for sure jake but it
certainly suggests that that
is the case unless you can find another
reason which i can't think of
of there being these excess deaths in
the context
of coronavirus you'd have to make an
assumption that it's
reasonably uh possible if not likely
that those are deaths that are related
to corona and they're just not being
counted okay and then fauci got
political again he was asked about
rallies now again it is
he was perfectly willing to answer when
it came to rallies trump rallies saying
that these political rallies they're
asking
for trouble they're really bad uh do you
remember fauci being particularly vocal
about the giant racial justice rallies
that were happening across the so-called
racial justice rallies that were
happening across the country
i don't remember him being a leader on
that particular issue i remember him
sort of receding into the background
but here was fauci going after trump's
after trump's rallies
put aside all of the issues of what
political implications a rally has
and just put that aside and look at it
purely
in the context of public health we know
that that is asking for trouble when you
do that we've seen that when you have
situations of congregate settings with a
lot of people without
masks the data speak for themselves it
happens
and now is even more so a worse time
to do that okay so trump responded this
morning on twitter
he went after fauci on twitter that
seems like a
bad move however much i disagree with
fauci on on a lot of this stuff and i
disagree with fauci about his general
strategy
i disagree with fauci on the way he's
characterized these problems i disagree
with fouchy about downplaying the
effects of lockdown while
up playing the uh well up playing the
threat of covid beyond what i think is
is entirely reasonable i think he's been
far too hesitant to convey
true data about the deadliness of covet
to people based on age
and condition stratification i think you
should be much clearer from the outset
and i think that his strategy overall
has not been good
trump going after fauci is a mistake and
he's tweeting incessantly about fouchy
today he tweeted today
tony's pitching arm is far more accurate
than his prognostications no problem no
masks who no longer likes lockdowns just
came out against trump was right
we saved two million american lives now
the 2 million american live statistic is
coming from that
very bad neil ferguson ridiculous study
uh in uh in britain not neal ferguson
the historian neil ferguson the
the epidemiologist in britain there's a
terrible study he did in which he
suggested that america would experience
2.2 million deaths from coronavirus if
everything was left alone
he says well we've only lost 200 000
therefore we save 2 million lives i
think that is scientifically dubious
but coming out against fauci in a time
when people are still worried about
kovid and you're saying that you're
gonna body surf a crowd it's just not a
good message it's just not
like is that your closing pitch i don't
understand how you win an election
on that basis especially because it
again allows the media to focus in on
you
rather than focusing in on the absolute
incompetent and wild
incoherence of joe biden and a radical
democratic party who will do
long-term damage to the institutions of
the united states alrighty
so we'll be back here a little bit later
today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wiedowsky our
associate producer is nick shien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina
hair and makeup is by nika geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
democrat senators humiliate themselves
at the confirmation hearings for scotus
nominee amy barrett
the cdc finds 85 percent of people
infected by kovid
wore their masks always or often and 56
of americans feel they're doing better
than they were four years ago
check it out on the michael knowles show